Well,
I think with the onslaught of celebrity
and our fascination with celebrity at
such a high pitched level that fashion,
which is kind of its younger sister or
second cousin,
um,
that idea of celebrity designers are
very glamorous.
They dress store let's the red carpet,
um,
the handbag business has gone crazy.
So the general population has really
understood fashion way that it never has
in generations before.
And it's reached,
I think a kind of celebrity,
semi celebrity level where the
designers,
the models,
uh,
and even,
you know,
Anna Winter and the devil wears Prada
have become large celebrities in their
own rights that has elevated the fashion
show to a semi,
you know,
Papa Razzi event where,
uh,
people can be photographed.
Famous people go to the shows,
famous models are seen in the
collections and designers that are world
renowned and famous are seen.
I'm going in and out of,
out of these shows and these tests.
The seeding is I'm slightly medieval
process.
Um,
but yes,
everybody likes to get the best seat
that they can.
And a lot of editors are very unhappy if
they're in the second row or the third
row,
which is basically considered Siberia.
So,
uh,
if you are an editor of good standing,
you usually have a front row seat at the
major collection.
That's the major shows in New York for
sure.
Oh,
the ORC leads that often,
I must say.
I think that's probably an appropriate
place for it to be.
Um,
New York is a solid place for fashion.
It's a consistently good place for
fashion.
However,
it's not the innovator,
it's not the real creative juice that we
all seek and that the retailers seek to
really get ourselves,
makes us excited about the stories we're
going to put your magazines and the
clothes that are going to be bought and
purchased in and ultimately bought in
the stores.
I'm particularly this season,
I don't think it was one of New York's
best seasons.
I think it was a very beige season.
And with that comes a certain sort of
banality.
Um,
there's nothing that glamorous and
dramatic about the color of beige.
Um,
so I think that's kind of a metaphor for
a little bit with the seasons.
However,
we do have a store and he's a major
story.
He continues to shock and rock and,
and push us forward.
And that's Marc Jacobs and indeed his,
both his collections this time we're,
we're very,
very powerful.
His Marc Jacobs collection,
which I just looked at in person and
uptight up close to feel the fabrics and
to see the accessories.
Um,
and to really see what he'd done was an
pastiche of ideas and styles and fabrics
and color.
And it was kind of Laura Engels and
little house on the prairie on crack.
I mean it was a crazy apron dress,
ruffled skirt,
but done in lyrics and Lemay.
So again,
mark pushes the boundaries.
He pushes the,
he dares to mixed fabrics and colors and
silhouettes and probably because he just
doesn't care that he's free to do what
he wants and he never repeats himself.
Um,
he's got favorite things that he does.
There's always a somewhere,
a seller all influenced,
I would say,
but clearly done a mark.
Um,
he likes to push people,
he likes to shake it all up,
you know,
he was a famous famous for his grunge
collection in the early nineties and he
continues to really rock our world,
but it's great and this show was
vibrant,
colorful,
collectic,
a real mix,
kept everybody on their toes yet again,
and is Marc by Marc Jacobs collection,
which is his younger line was just as
delightful and enchanting and if I was,
you know,
18 to 25 and that was sort of my
demographic and,
and my age group,
I would be around running,
running,
running to those two stores,
into those boutiques to get those
clothes.
So he really gets you excited and really
makes you want to buy clothes.
He makes you want the handbags.
Fantastic.
Everyone said the it bag is over,
nobody needs groovy bags anymore.
That's all passe.
Forget it.
Mark has just made us all realize that
there is another bag and he had about
five that were expect macular,
um,
in his bark collection.
So I think New York is glad to have
mark.
I'm certainly personally,
professionally happy to have him.
He makes it exciting,
he's on a level with the best designers
in Europe,
particularly Paris as well as Miuccia
Prada in Milan,
and really keeping fashion exciting and
interesting and pushing it forward.
You know,
I admire Anna winter so much because,
um,
because of her unbelievable power and,
and because she does a fantastic job at
vogue,
but particularly in this question
because she really tries to promote and
spent a large portion of her time and
vogue's time and effort to promote the
next generation.
It's just really hard business to be
that competitive in,
you know,
these guys are coming up with four to
six collections a year.
That creative process is unbelievably
challenging.
I mean,
think about an artist that has to come
up with a whole of four to six times a
year.
I mean,
they just don't,
you know,
they,
they do the same thing.
They moved,
they evolve over time,
over a decade,
over five years.
These guys are asked to kind of reinvent
the wheel as well as learning their
trade and trying to have viable
businesses.
So it's really hard,
I think,
for the young generation to come forward
to push forward some of the kinds of new
up and comers that have been around
several seasons.
I'm disappointed to say that they
faltered a little bit.
They're not able to keep going with the
kind of expectation that we all put on
them.
Um,
but,
but Anna and the vogue fun and the CFTA,
the council of fashion designers of
America really are trying to support
fashion at that starting level to really
give these young designers the support
and the financial
cash that they need to continue and also
to sort of offer kind of mentoring
program.
But,
um,
no,
as far as New York is concerned,
that's why it's not been a kind of
season of newness,
but London,
um,
which is happening as we speak right now
is and continues to be a real
interesting place where all those free
ideas and kind of crazy eccentric things
that the English are known for are able
to come out and have created
unbelievable talent.
So,
um,
I think London is really the place where
you watch it the next best generation of
designers.